[inaudible]
how many people?
Japan is still pretty mysterious and
that's not only because it's a country
where people push that dog's arounds in
prams and drink coffee in places full of
cats mode at all.
In fact,
just like being an overpopulated area
with scarce natural resources,
Japan is one of the richest and most
developed countries in the world with
the highest average life expectancy on
the planet.
It's
so,
it's no wonder that it tends to amaze us
in the west,
but hold on.
Amendments here because Japan wasn't
always the economic powerhouse that we
know today.
In fact,
it was quite the opposite until the mid
19th century.
This country operated under a political
and economic system that was very
similar to medieval a Europe's at that
time,
Japan was a poor and backward territory,
closed off to the world with a strongly
stratified society.
Now the question is,
how did the great change occur?
How did Japan managed to her eyes up
from its status as a poor rural country
to that of a great industrial power?
Was it all because of the influence and
help of the United States after the
Second World War?
Was it the result of a meticulously
designed the plan by the government?
Well,
we can say that this entire process
involved to major stages.
We'll talk about the first one in this
video,
which began 150 years ago with these so
called Meiji Restoration and yes,
this did happen 150 years ago.
2018 is the hundred 50th anniversary of
this happening.
The second stage,
which we're going to talk about in a
future video,
and don't forget to subscribe,
so you get that began at the end of the
Second World War.
But having said this,
let's stop with the story.
So here we go.
Meiji restoration 150 years ago,
the Meiji Restoration of 1868 and did
the dominance of the Tokugawa,
a clan of it for more than 250 years in
1603 and virtually supplanters of the
emperor's power,
turning them into the great lords of
Japan.
We're talking about a long period during
which Japan remained isolated from all
contact with the outside world and well
many western countries were throwing
themselves into the industrial
revolution.
This isolation calls Japan to retain
social,
political,
and economic structures that were more
similar to the Middle Ages than modern
times.
At that time,
Japan was a feudal society,
dominated by warlords.
Zenned for no less than 14 centuries had
behaved like a kind of vassal state of
the Chinese emba.
All of this very,
very different from the Japan that we
know today.
We're talking about a country that
prohibited the use of its ports by
foreigners to stop their interference
from contaminating the local culture and
traditions.
Of course,
that also ended any trade and any
possibility that it's political estates
would move to the beat of the Times.
This was the situation until in 1853 a
modern u s fleet arrived in Tokyo Bay
with a mission and a message.
Either the Japanese authorities excepted
ends allow trade or that half to face
the consequences steamboats the hawks of
the Pacific break their rest.
Four boats are enough to make us lose
sleep.
At night.
Japanese poem referring to the American
ships that arrived in the country in
1853 obviously the fall less developed
Japanese institutions could do little in
the face of a modern technologically
advanced war fleet,
so they had no choice but to accept and
it
that was the beginning of the end of the
Tokugawa regime within a few years,
disgusted by the morven palpable loss of
sovereignty by the humiliation of
feeling like a poor and and capable of
country,
and having seen the decline of the
Chinese Empire,
the Samurai Samurai,
which by the way were much more modern
than those we usually see in movies,
took control and they restored imperial
Japan.
We're talking about the well known Meiji
Restoration,
which against all odds launched Japan
into the arms of a broad reform program
that changed practically every field off
to rule given the enormous
technological,
economic and military superiority of the
western powers.
The best way to preserve Japan
sovereignty equals to take notes and to
promote the country's development.
I do.
You know what?
While they did just that within a few
years,
not even the Japanese themselves could
recognize Japan.
These are the steps of the country
followed to jump from the feudal age
right into the modern world.
So listen up
at the political level,
many of the old institutions were
terminated and an independent judiciary
power,
a bicameral legislature and a modern
prefectural system were introduced to
govern the countries,
various regions.
The old taxes on the sale of rice were
replaced by a lamb's tax,
which had two huge advantages.
First,
it facilitated the calculation of the
revenues the government obtained each
year after all,
nick amounts of lands doesn't change,
but the rice production does change
every year,
which allowed the government to,
for example,
design finance and build several
infrastructure projects.
This then help the time and lands
ownership with precision establishing a
modern property rights system for it.
Yeah,
well that was not all being aware of the
importance of knowledge and new
technologies in 1872 just four years
after the Meiji Restoration,
the Japanese government to establish a
universal primary education system
because within a few years the Tokyo
Institute of Technology and the
University of Tokyo were create it.
And of course in addition to everything
we've seen,
Japan is openness was also encouraged.
Foreign experts and professionals we
have attracted to transmit their
knowledge and many Japanese students
were scholarships to study both in
Europe and in the United States.
The results of this whole process was
that in just 50 years Japan managed to
go through it's own industrial
revolution.
That's one third of the time it took
Europe
that way.
In the following decades Japan
continued.
It's take off process and completely
changed and that's also when it began
extending its influenced up neighboring
countries like Korea,
China,
Russia and Taiwan in 1902 cause they
also signed a friendship agreement with
Great Britain and agreements.
And this not only boosted its industry,
but when World War One arrived,
it enabled Japan to become an important
supplier,
further boosting its economy.
In these years,
many Japanese entrepreneurs became
million ads for one reason or another.
In the ends,
when countries boost their trade,
every party usually benefits.
Mr.
Trump.
Take note here,
but folks,
that's how we got to the year 1926 the
year when the darkest time in Japan
began.
Nope.
War Economy,
1926 the,
yeah,
that's Emperor Hirohito ascended the
throne where he remained all the way
until 1989 and from that exact moment in
the 1920s Japan began to deepen its most
warlike profile.
In 1931 Japanese troops occupied the
Chinese province of Manchuria where they
not only committed and enormous number
of crimes,
but in occupying the province,
they also triggered the tense relations
between Japan and most of the western
powers.
And that's not once everything he said
came to power,
the government again,
to boost the war industry to such an
extent that in 1931 while the trips
invaded Manchuria Japanese government
authorized and encouraged the creation
of cartels among large companies,
especially among the heavy industry.
That is to say the industry related to
steel boat machinery,
truck construction,
et cetera.
That way the government is good urge
launch companies do agreeing to increase
production as quickly as possible if
while limiting the entry of new
competitors,
and that's not all in the following
years.
The government also injected a lot of
capital into these companies until it
became co owner of several of them.
All the while our military spending,
it just wouldn't stop growing.
Of course,
this massive amounts of government
intervention in the economy,
they had had consequences.
It's more businesses were ravaged and
almost every civilian industry closed
long before the U s bombing during World
War Two the consequences of this war
economy didn't only lead to a more
authoritarian governments since a
greater military influence,
which ultimately ended up in a war,
but also in the general impoverishment
of the Japanese.
Yes.
Now,
of course,
military material had to be produced of
goods that would improve people's lives
on a day to day basis.
More rifles,
less soon machines ended up with the
country being much poorer in the end.
You know what?
It's not strange at all.
History teaches us that militaristic
policies tend to be very efficient and
boost the power of the elite.
Well,
impoverishing the majority.
The fact is that as we all know,
at the end of World War Two Japan wasn't
only a defeated country,
the Japanese economy,
it was shattered and the Japanese had
gone back decades in terms of their
standard.
Yeah.
Living
all this,
of course,
in addition to the tragedy of having
lost more than 3 million lives during
the conflicts,
nope.
Some of you may be wondering,
well,
what happens after the war?
How did Japan managed to become such a
great power within just a few years?
Well,
folks,
we're going to get into those answers in
a future video here on visual politics.
So far in this one,
we've already seen how Japan made the
great leap and went from the Middle Ages
to the modern wells,
and in the future we're going to explore
even more.
So I really hope you enjoy this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did,
and don't forget to subscribe the brand
new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it.
Our friends at the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine.
Also,
of course,
this channel is possible because of
Patriarchy and all patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next video.